one of the funniest videos I've seen in
a long time
over the weekend goes viral this is
proud boys met by a group I think called
Patriot front it's hard to tell exactly
who these people are because they wear
masks over their faces and this is a
group
as we in recent months maybe a year
you've seen this group Patriot front
come to the fore and they March and they
seem really on the nose and I think I've
never really heard of this group and I'm
pretty in it you know it's my job to
read about what's going on politically
in the United States especially on the
right I don't really know anything about
these guys it seems kind of like a well
it's right there in the name it seems
kind of like a front you know it's we
know that federal agents infiltrate
these supposedly right-wing Grassroots
groups we've seen the memoranda from the
FBI we've seen these guys get caught do
you remember at the justice for January
6th rally where pretty much no one
showed up other than journalists and
federal agents there was this famous
picture taken of guys who are obviously
feds they're all wearing the same
brandless clothing that they've all got
the same haircut they probably got done
at Langley or at the FBI headquarters
they're all wearing the same Shades
they're all checking their five and
they're six and they're seven it's just
they're all wearing the same Garmin
watch it was such a joke and what's
funny now by the way is if you Google
this picture if you look for it on
Google you won't turn up if you look for
it on Twitter it won't turn up you can
say justice for January 6th rally feds
j6 feds whatever it doesn't show up you
can't find it I need to go to Bing to
find that picture even though that
picture was everywhere at the time so we
know that this kind of stuff happens and
there's a video
of The Proud boys going up to these
supposed American neo-nazis and saying
get the hell out of here you guys are
not part of us you're obviously feds go
away
[Music]
see the guy in like the mullet proud boy
waving the American flag going up to
these
supposed American Nazis saying get out
of here we don't want you here you're
obviously just infiltrator pack shills
go away
[Music]
and they do
back them off
they do all these guys who very
conveniently are covered up in their
Shades and their face masks they get out
of here and some of the proud boys then
tried to I think unmask them and it
created a whole issue now look I don't
know if those guys are feds I don't know
if those guys are there just to try to
make the right look batters I I really I
don't know I don't I don't know I don't
really care however there is one good
piece of evidence
that these guys might have I'm not
saying that they're actual employees of
the federal government that they might
have some kind of connection you know to
the federal government one piece of
evidence here
that that they're feds is from Adam
kinzinger former
Republican member of Congress who's a
total Shale for the liberal
establishment he tweets out he says
these people
referring to conservative pundits who
were laughing about this video
these people all blue checks are
celebrating a seemingly Maga assault on
federal officers now I don't know what
this really is but take a gander at the
comments of the patriots who love
America
and reading that comment you say hold on
wait
you're admitting that Patriot front is a
bunch of feds did you Adam kinzinger who
is not the swiftest politician out there
that's why he's no longer in congress
not necessarily the sharpest hole in the
Jed
he's out there he's saying this is
outrageous all these conservatives are
laughing at an attack
let's see I say no man you're supposed
to pretend that they're not federal
agents and anyway just a reminder
that uh
the you really shouldn't believe
everything you read in the liberal
establishment papers because the reality
of what's going on on the right is not
the way that it is portrayed and I think
people are beginning to wake up to this
and you're seeing it reflected in the
polls and priorities of the real
conservatives right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 as central banks in countries
such as China India and Australia begin
transitioning to digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with a digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
seize part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold they are the people that I
trust for gold I'm very pleased to have
some Birch gold and thousands of other
people are very happy about that too
Birch gold will help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in gold
you don't have to pay a penny out of
pocket when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98.98 get your
free info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on text Knolls knwles to 98 98 98. right
now head on over to gcu.edu I love Grand
Canyon University Grand Canyon
University is one of the first schools
that I ever visited when I was on my
college speaking tour I've been to
dozens and dozens of schools and at GCU
I love I now work with two of the
students who brought me to GCU that
first time one of them here at the daily
wire one over at the Young Americas
Foundation it's just a great place and
with everything on your plate earning
your degree online might seem impossible
well Grand Canyon University's online
programs are designed to make earning
your degree easy and accessible no
matter your age or stage in life whether
you are a busy professional looking to
advance your career career or a
stay-at-home parent juggling family
responsibilities gcu's online courses
give you the flexibility that you need
to learn on your own terms Grand Canyon
University specializes in helping you
fit your bachelor's Master's or doctoral
degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customize scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
huh if you're ready to take your
education to the next level you need
Grand Canyon University find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University that
is gcu.edu
gcu.edu do you remember
it's about a year ago maybe even over a
year ago
Texas governor Greg Abbott along with
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis some other
Republican leaders decide to send
illegal aliens out of their states to
Liberal strongholds Governor DeSantis
famously sent the illegal aliens to
Martha's Vineyard which was hilarious
Governor Abbott though he got a little
less publicity for it but he was sending
the illegal aliens to places like
Chicago into places like New York and at
the time
here is what New York City liberal
Democrat mayor Eric Adams had to say
about a political leader shipping
illegal aliens to other states away
from their cities and states
this is horrific when you think about
what the governor is doing the governor
of Texas
after a month of traveling across the
border placing on the bus with no
direction to come here uh to New York
and New York is a city that has always
represented the democratic values and
the values of our city of showing our
compassion and that's what we're doing
today that's what we're doing today this
is horrific
to ship illegal aliens just because you
don't want them in your state in your
city you're going to just ship them out
of there
pass the buck outrageous
until
mayor Adams just got caught doing
exactly the same thing actually not
exactly the same thing he is shipping
the illegal aliens to other states
he's shipped them to over a dozen states
he's also shipping them to other
countries
Eric Adams so it's horrific to send
illegal aliens from Texas to New York
he's shipping them to it to over a dozen
other states and to five countries
including China
Venezuela Colombia Peru
and Ecuador
awful awful when a republican does
something
wonderful when a Democrat does the same
or a more egregious version of the very
same thing
I'm not going to say I'm not going to
even bring up if the shoe were on the
other foot you know that's the Epitaph
on The Headstone of conservatism imagine
if the rules were reversed
just pointing out that when when the
Liberals make these arguments this is
horrific violation of Human Rights how
could you ever see they don't really
mean it
they're just lying and using that
political issue as a cudgel to beat the
Republicans into submission and The Rock
ribbed conservatives see through this I
strongly suspect there are plenty of
liberals who listen to this show I'm
pleased to say but the people who are
listening to this show if they're not
rock group conservatives they're at
least independent thinkers who see
through a lot of this piffle but there
were people the squishes in the
Republican Party
and the centrists and the people on who
just want to be liked by The Washington
Post in the New York Times they're the
ones who will join the chorus of the
Eric Adams's who say well you know
that's really awful you know actually
that's really awful to do that to those
illegal aliens we shouldn't we're better
than that
no it's a that's a Perfectly Natural and
just response to foreign aliens in your
country in your country or in your
municipality illegally it is Perfectly
Natural and right and just to ship those
people out of there
they just don't want us to do it because
Mass migration is in large part a
political operation to undermine the
political and electoral viability of
Republicans throughout the United States
that's why the libs did it that's why
the libs continue to do it and when the
caught when they have to bear the costs
of that the housing and the taxes when
they have to bear the political costs of
that which is even Democrat people in
Democrat cities don't want to have to
pay for this stuff then they will
sometimes ship them away and they'll
ship them back to the Republican states
very often so that they don't have to
deal with it what a great clip that was
I know you want more of them you got to
subscribe ring the bell to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time